in Belgium coronavirus has hit hard and
these are the people who see it up close
today we joined an ambulance crew in
Brussels the shift starts and there's a
call straightaway a woman struggling to
breathe properly a familiar complaint
the crew always wear special hazmat
suits the patient reveals she works in a
retirement home but wasn't given
protective equipment that puts her at
high risk of getting the virus she's
taken to hospital and handed over to the
doctors there
the ambulances are deep cleaned by fire
services between each and every call out
it's a laborious process but it's based
on the single tenets of safety first
every ambulance must be disinfected very
carefully as you see here just at my
sides every ambulance have to pass this
line and has been complete completed sir
disaffected we're back on the road and
there's another call out immediately a
dash across Brussels rushing through the
streets of a locked-down city this
patient is taken to a different Hospital
a specialist coronavirus enter those
tents are where patients are assessed if
they simply walk in well the ambulance
arrived here at some Peter's Hospital in
the middle of Brussels this is what's
called the main reference hospital for
treating coronavirus patients now been
taken on to the ward the team now
getting back into the ambulance but from
here they are going to have to go to
somewhere else so this vehicle and
everything inside it can be
decontaminated call out cleaning call
out cleaning it's a grim recurring theme
and also a grueling one every day the
ambulance crew see the ravages of this
virus however experienced they are this
is taking its toll
Damona to spell de niro virus nose wash
la fatigued wheels ferocity tellegio
a fatigue on sedative are attent
decontamination safe at ago on a salad
bar mr. poster poster Tomica legs are
completely filled as original these are
for so it have a non stop these are the
people who respond first they say
they're busier than ever we leave them
but be getting another call any moment
other person Sky News Brussels